[Musique]
je sais que tu as besoin d'argent on
leur fait pas le con
pour qui ça
ça va
mon père est mort
pêche maintenant et à l'heure de notre
mort
les enfants tenir une vieille promesse
que j'ai faite à mon papa chéri
[Musique]
il est crevé
je peux pas te laisser une seconde sans
que tu fasses de la merde toi
tu vas me faire plaisir à moi alors
quoi
j'ai pas envie de participer à ça moi je
te file de l'argent tu as pas
l'impression de participer c'est quoi
cette histoire dis-moi ce qui se passe
je compte la famille je te laisserai pas
prendre ma place
tu as des beaux enfants
[Musique]
elle a dit que c'était réversible
exactement et ça c'est grave
[Musique]